since the beginning of 2025 I've been
getting about one to three High ticket
clients every single day automatically
without sales calls or a sales team or
anything like that essentially through
strategic low and mid ticket offers it's
a new way that I discovered to create
promote and selos and very quickly day
became a Cornerstone inside my business
allowing me to generate 3 four or 5,000
a day while working no more than 4 hours
operating at 90% profit marching so
those offers are incredibly powerful and
because they are I decided to launch a
4-week Sprint where I'm helping clients
over four weeks to essentially launch
create and sell those low and mid ticket
offers and get high ticket client
through dolls and I just finalized the
first training which is essentially
about creating a low andit ticket offer
that's going to get high ticket clients
and I decided to share that for free
with the public inside this YouTube
video so in a minute we're going to jump
over to my screen but before we do let
me introduce myself to the people who
don't know me so my name is MZ I'm the
4-Hour consultant and over the last 8
years I've generated well over $100
million in Clan results and sold about
$8 million in Consulting products myself
and the way I've been doing that is
through high ticket offers and
especially over the last couple years
through sales teams through appointment
Setters through sales calls but after a
while I wanted to find an easier way
especially a way where I'm not riant on
teams are filling my calendar which
really got me to creating systems like
these creating offers like these like
low ticket and mid ticket offers that
get me high ticket clients on autopilot
so let's actually jump over to my screen
and and let me walk you through the
process of creating your own low mid
ticket off all right so essentially
here's the core document and as you can
see I just actually put this into GMA
and it's in the process of being
finalized but it's good enough to share
it out with you already so I'm calling
this the daily High ticket client
machine there again we're using low and
mid ticket offers to get one to three
High ticket clients a day on
autopilot now diving into this we first
got to understand the buyer blueprint so
how do we actually attract the right
buyers and who are the right buyers I've
been launching and using low and mid
ticket offers for a long time and I fell
for the Trap of saying let's just launch
and promote any low ticket offer because
after all buyers are better than leads
and I think all of us have heard that
before and that's kind of true but
here's the truth you can get unqualified
leads but you can also get unqualified
buyers and both are bad for business and
essentially a waste of time so there's
really only three types of buyers you
need to know we got the unqualified
buyers they don't have the problem or
the desire that essentially or high
ticket off offer solves they may
purchase your low ticket offer but will
never buy your premium products so they
really drain your resources for zero
long-term gain you got the aligned
buyers they have the problem desire that
your high ticket offer solves they're
generally interested in bigger Solutions
but they La the awareness and because of
it will likely not purchase that right
away so they're perfect future clients
with proper nurturing and then we got
the gold we got the qualified buyers
they have the problem desire that your
premium offer your high ticket offer
solves and are already aware of it
they're already aware of the problem
that your high ticket offer solves so as
soon as they actually purchase your low
ticket or mid ticket offer and receive
your value they'll will essentially beg
you to become your high ticket clients
and purchase without handholding so all
it takes is a payment link to get them
to
buy a 5 10 20 30k product and your
entire system everything we're building
here your daily High client machine
should be designed to attract aligned
buyers and convert them into qualified
buyers and attract qualified buyers
right away now depending on the traffic
Source you're using it's really hard to
fully avoid the unqualified buyers this
isn't like a black and white thing but
the goal is to get as little unqualified
buyers as
possible so let's speak a bit about the
old way versus the new way because again
I've been doing low ticket wrong and
I've built large lists with leads that
didn't end up purchasing they didn't
respond to my marketing emails that
didn't respond to my campaigns and that
again is a bit of like a wasted effort
so what is it that most people or also
what I did get wrong when I did low
ticket offers so generally the typical
low ticket offers they just tend to pull
in unqualified buyers because of the
Let's Just Launch anything mindset maybe
a few unqualified buyers actually become
aligned buyers actually become that
second tier of buyers which might
signals to you like oh this campaign
might be working when in reality and
especially after time you'll figure out
it's just really luck and you can't
really control it so what what causes
that the common mistake are that a
people create those High effort super
time consuming products so think of
ebooks it's the most common one that so
many people use and it's complete
garbage there
people are forced to read through an
entire book to eventually become a
client and yes there are ways to do that
well but there's ways to get highte
clients a lot faster and better and the
same thing really goes for the 3 Day 4
day five day or 7day challenges they
just make really bad low ticket offers
compared to what I'm about to share with
you here in a second then on the other
Spectrum we got like the products that
build zero brand connection so think of
like the PDFs or the lead magnets where
literally people don't even see your
face they don't hear your voice it just
builts very little no love and Trust
then diverse thing diverse low ticket
offers in my opinion and bought some of
these and they actually are quite
counterproductive it's like selling paid
sales pitches with little actual value
so think paid
webinars and then we got the classic
ones we see that on Black Friday all the
time where people actually offer their
High ticket programs on a discount if
you bought a week before Black Friday
they told you on the sales call it's
five grand and a week later on Black
Friday it's like oh you can buy it for
500 bucks this just creates or puts you
into a very bad position positioning in
the market where people look at you as a
lower ticket solution and you also have
the last problem or the last mistake
which is solving problems completely
misaligned with your high ticket offer
so you might say Hey you know you know
what I got this great idea I want to
launch that thing and you get it out in
the market people buy it but they don't
become High ticket clients because it's
not aligned with your high ticket offer
so that really comes down to Let's Just
Launch anything or what I hear often is
like let's just ask my Facebook audience
what they want and because of that
you're very likely going to maybe or
likely attract people that will never
become your high ticket clients there's
better ways to do that so let's talk
about the client magnet method the low
ticket offers we're actually creating I
call them client magnet offers because
they are designed to be a magnet for
high tiet clients so obviously we want
them to pull in aligned buyers and
transform them into qualified buyers
right so pulling aligned buyers going
back to this turn them into qualified
buyers that's the core goal and we want
to minimize the unqualified sales that
waste your time in resources is on your
list they ask the questions that you
know we just end up being in a super
long sales cycle to make uh a few sales
um we want to build Channel and brand
connection through video and audio
experiences we we want offers that are
quick and easy to consume so think in
like one sitting because we want to turn
those buyers into clients as quickly as
possible and on that not too we don't
just want it to be easy to consume but
actually create a result very fast
preferably while they're consuming it or
then at least in less than seven days it
solves one meaningful problem usually a
symptom of the bigger problem and it
naturally amp if I awareness of the
problem your high ticket offer solved so
there's a bit of like
sequencing but let's look at the
critical components a I would highly
recommend especially for the client
magnet to pricee it as an impulse
purchase while the price is a lot less
important than pricing your high ticket
offer what we want is stay intent from
the right people but I would price it
anywhere between $15 to $50 including
your order bump I give you an example I
have offers out there that I sell for
seven bucks but the average order value
goes up to $15 because of the bump what
people additionally
purchase um and I would keep it below
$50 I tried $97 too it likely will get
you the highest quality buyers but it
will just massively increase the cost
per acquisition where in most in
instances I haven't found that to
actually be beneficial then number two
is a connection Builder we want to
create an
experience of you and build that no love
and Trust right we want that buyer offer
that magnet to build no love and Trust
that's really the only way how we can
how we are kind of like not in a
position where we have to give away our
best stuff on social media but can
actually sell our best stuff use that
best stuff to build no love and Trust
because people that pay they pay
attention and when that allows us or
it's delivered in a format that also
builds no love and trust it it's really
the best case scenario then quick wins
again we want to be able to deliver
results either during consumption or in
one week or less again easy to digest I
always recommend info products call it
however you want master classes
workshops it doesn't matter but make it
consumable in under 3
hours then strategic problem solving we
want to solve one specific problem that
when solved
highlights the need for your high ticket
solution so it's making it a natural
upsell where essentially pre-sell your
next offer without being pushy what does
that mean simply by solving actually
solving the problem that you promis to
solve inside your low ticket offer it
will naturally create the awareness of
what the next problem is going to be
that's really what makes a client magnet
really powerful and I'll give you actual
examples here in a second of what that
looks like in my
business
so when going through content like this
it's so easy like I just know myself
it's so easy to over complicate this and
just trying to make it perfect so when
I'm doing this it's it's like literally
I can I can launch uh client magnets in
like like in an hour because I'm just
following a protoc a protocol on how to
do this and and here's the protocol I'm
using so I'm creating a hypothesis the
hypothesis is like what problem can I
solve quickly what's a problem that I
want to get out in the market then I
want to sell the hypothesis test if
people actually want to solve that
problem and then I deliver the solution
life right so I'm doing a live Workshop
rather than creating courses or products
to those first buyers and when that
worked well meaning the buyers that
bought actually also become became
clients then I start selling a recording
I start sending traffic to the recording
I sell it to New prospects and then when
that works well I only then start
turning that recording into like a
beautiful looking course that will just
further increase the experience but and
then we obviously scale what works but
essentially the core focus is on making
sales first before we make things look
nice and
cute so and whenever we go through this
protocol we only move to the next step
if your hypothesis proves true so we
only move to step step two once we got a
hypothesis we only moved from step two
to step three when we actually sold the
hypothesis
right
so choosing your next step again a low
ticket offer a client magnet only makes
sense if the buyers actually convert
into something bigger ticket so while
your client magnet can lead directly
into a high ticket offer it can
absolutely do that just keep in mind
that if it does you will likely still
need a sales call I have in very few
instances I had a low ticket offer
actually create a high ticket client by
payment link without interaction with me
without like a back and forth but with
that said even if you choose that way
it's going to be way more fun at this
point because you're talking to prezel
prospect so it's going to change your
Paradigm if you used to selling to Colt
leads on sales conversation
but it's not the promise of this
training I I promised you that I'm going
to show you how to get high ticket
clients on autopol so to achieve that we
need what I call a high ticket onramp
fancy vert for Mid ticket offers so in
either case whatever you choose of those
two scenarios just choose one upgrade
offer we don't want to create confusion
with too many offers just choose one
upgrade offer to get people into even if
you have multiple options now before we
move on few things to remember price
really doesn't matter again I've sold
30k deals from a $20 client magnet offer
easy absolutely um it can also be any
type of offer right it can be a
one-on-one offer it can be an hency
service it can be a membership it can be
a physical product I've seen and
consulted on all different variations
where I've had an info product lead to a
physical product as an example all of
that
works what really matters what's the
secret this new way behind making client
magnet work that actually turns buyers
into highte clients is called Problem
sequencing so if this was too long and
you didn't read picking the right
problem to solve inside your client
magnet will attract qualified buyers so
that's the first thing when you then are
actually able to solve that
problem it will naturally turn buyers
into high ticket clients that's it if
you do those two things you will get one
to three High tiet clients every sing
all day by just doing those two things
so let's understand problems because
that's where the success comes from
there's two kinds of problems right you
heard that probably before if you're
into marketing people always run away
from something meaning pain or they run
towards something meaning desire so what
that really means in simple terms is a
problem can be an unfulfilled desire
they run two wordss like building a
seven fig business getting high ticket
client on autopilot all of that good
stuff or it can be an unresolved issue
they run away from like I'm tired of
taking zes calls every single day I
never want to take a zes call again so
we got two kinds of problems issues and
desires now the types of problems
there's really only three the tip of the
pyramid we have the symptomatic problem
this is the small specific quick to
solve problem that we put or that we
focus on in our low ticket offers we
then got the journey problem so when one
solved the symptomatic problem what are
the road blocks after solving the
symptomatic problem but before solving
the core problem which you fix in your
high ticket offer what are the journey
problems and then we got the core
problem so if you have a high ticket
offer right now then that's what you are
doing inside your high ticket offer it's
that ultimate issue or that ultimate
desire that your high ticket offer
solves again I'm going to give you
examples here in a
second let's speak about the core
problem so this is the ultimate issue
slash the desire think of it as the big
umbrella problem your high ticket offer
solves I give you an example there is no
way to solo sell deliver and scale High
ticket offers to 100K a month in profits
while working just 20 hours a week
that's the core problem that we solve
with my clients inside the 4-Hour
consultant so through my high ticket
offer then let's think of the journey
problem so the journey problem it's the
roadblocks experienced after solving the
symptomatic problem but before the core
problem is solved I give you the example
I need more traffic to quickly get
customers and upgrade them into high
ticket clients I solved that through the
high ticket onramp AIT ticket offer for
me that's the four Consulting bundle
early on in that video I told you that
this is a 4-week Sprint where the
training we're running through right now
is part of that four week Sprint so
that's kind of like the journey problem
and then we got the symptomatic problem
which is the small specific quick to
solve problem and here's the important
piece almost everyone with the core
problem experiences so an example my
Revenue stalled because selling High
ticket offers is too time consuming my
sales processes through timec consuming
and I can't take more sales calls and
the way we solve that is through my
client magnet through a low ticket offer
right so people get into my world from
suffering from the problem like my
Revenue stalled I I can't get more High
tick of clients because the sales
process is too timec consuming I can
solve that in less than a few hours with
my client magnet and when people solved
that through installing low and mid
ticket offers they're like well great
this worked but now I need more people
to get into my low and mid ticket offers
where I then upsell them into my bundle
right my bundle is essentially the point
where I give them all of my client
getting strategies all of my ads all of
my templates all of my messaging scripts
my social posts basically outbound
organic content and ads that they can
swipe steal andall to fill their low and
mid ticket offer so they will eventually
be a to it's like damn I get so many
high tiet clients every single day how
do I get this 200k a month solo
operating at 90% profit margins that
will again get them into my high ticket
offer we'll go a bit deeper into that
here shortly but essentially what is
problem sequencing it's understanding
that in from a good perspective
like that one problem will always lead
to an next problem it's just how we
humans rir we solve a problem and when
solving a problem we might accomplish
the desire but we're rarely ever
satisfied so we just think about the
next problem that we want to solve it's
a never ending cycle which makes the
whole marketing and offer creation work
in the first place so problem sequencing
the master key problem sequencing if you
actually master that it's slightly
Advanced but I'll make it super easy for
you it will solve almost every marketing
messaging and sales problem you'll ever
have it's it's freaking great and you
don't need to read a book you don't need
to pay a copyright or thousands of
dollars just understand this and your
marketing will become a lot easier leads
leads in marketing and sales and sales
are lost mostly 80% off the time through
confusion and bad communication I give
you an example Prospect books a call
with you believing he has problem a you
know that the prospect actually doesn't
just have problem a they have problem a
b and c so you then under call try to
sell problem a b and c what you think
they need instead of what they want so
now you are creating confusion in the
sales process and even though both of
you want to accomplish the same thing
you're ending up not making the sale
because the prospect doesn't feel
understood and that comes from problem
sequencing so the problem sequencing
example in the 4-Hour consultant
is essentially step number one when we
look at the symptomatic problem my
client magnet is again the problem that
we solve inside is that the revenue stld
because selling High ticket offers is
too time consuming with the current
sales process the solution designed low
and mid ticket offers that get high
ticket clients on autopoll the offer the
daily High ticket client machine
essentially what we're running through
right now then the journey problem which
is the high ticket on ramp the problem
is I need more traffic to quickly get
customers and upgrading into I tiet
clients for the low and mid ticket offer
so solution access all the internal
client getting strategies DM scripts
messenger ready offers ads templates
text Tech emails Pages automations Etc
inside the 4-Hour Consulting bundle and
then the core problem which is inside my
high ticket offer the 4our consultant is
there's no way to solo sell deliver and
scale High ticket offers 200k a month in
profits working no more than 20 hours
weekly so the solution is efficient
business models that gets high ticket
clients
automatically and delivers results in 2
hours a week at scale and the offer is
the 4-Hour consultant now yours doesn't
have to be this perfect right away it
took me months to arrive here and I made
Millions along the way so for now just
get the simplest clearest version of
your buyer's problem and solutions out
of your head and onto a Google Document
so you can start with something but let
me help you do that so let's go together
through a process of problem sequencing
so let's identify the core
problem so three questions what problem
does your high ticket offer solve think
of desires and issues write everything
down then what do your clients write
testimonials about or refer you for if
you don't have testimonials then ask
your clients and if you do have testimon
actually look through dolls you will
actually figure out fairly quickly what
that core problem is and if you had to
narrow it down to one ultimate issue or
desire what would that be again I gave
you my examples before for me it's no
way to solo sell deliver in scale High
ticket offers 200k month in profits
working no more than 20 hours weekly
solution efficient business model that
gets I to declines automatically and
delivers results in two hours a week at
scale I'll actually pull up a
testimonial from a client of mine that
initially helped me to actually arrive
at this
statement now with that defined let's
actually look at the symptomatic problem
so here four questions ask yourself
which problems do people most frequently
come to you to solve like what's the
thing they actually reach out for not
the things you think they need but what
are the things they reach out for they
ask you for what's the first thing they
want the first thing they tell you they
need on the calls that you have with
them and what parts of your work do
clients most appreciate and love you for
what negging issues can you fix in one
afternoon or a day and what have they
been trying to get done that you can
help them create in a few hours think of
things that they are aware of that they
need I give you an example here again my
problem is like Revenue stall because
selling High ticket offers is too timec
consuming so the solutionist designing
low and mid ticket offers most of the
people that I'm attracting they have
already thought of creating a low and
mid ticket offer so it makes it a great
symptoma problem to solve now here's a
few challenges that I want to warn you
of very likely you will attempt to sell
a problem you think they need to solve
instead of what they want to solve
that's the biggest disconnect for so
many people reenter your focus on what
they want to solve not what you think
they need to solve do that in your high
ticket offer not in your client magnet
then another thing is making promis that
are too big or vague usually the bigger
the promise you make you start to solve
so many different problems to be able to
accomplish that that it's very hard to
be specific so in general especially for
client magnets smaller specific problems
are not just easier to sell but they're
also easier to keep so that goes hand in
hand with being too broad instead of
focusing on a clear problem solution and
outcome so important for you
align the symptomatic problem with the
core problem again don't fall for the
mindset of Let's Just Launch any low
ticket off or trap go through the
sequencing right learn to chunk down
your problem into pieces think of the
analogy there is only one way to eat an
elephant one bite at a time what is that
for you what's the elephant that you
help your clients eat inside your high
ticket program what's that core problem
and then how do they start solving that
what are the steps because if you spend
the time unpacking that unpacking Your
solution into the macro and micro steps
they actually going to find hundreds of
specific symptomatic problems to choose
from now lastly let's identify your
journey problem so ask yourself what new
problems arise after they solve the
symptomatic problem and what Milestones
checkpoints and roope blocks might they
encounter on the journey to solving the
core problem so I'm give you an example
again they've just built a lowend a mid
ticket offer they sold it so now they
want more traffic to quickly get more
customers and upgrade those into high
take clients the solution is access all
of my internal client getting strategies
DM scripts ads messenger ready offers
etc etc to make that happen now I'd
recommend that you choose about one to
two Journey problems to focus on again
don't obsess over Perfection the market
will decide what they want to buy and
what works no great offer is ever
created in silence but in motion so you
want to launch as fast as humanly
possible and refine from there because
you can spend hours thinking through all
that you launch it and then figure out
that the market never wanted that and it
can be the other way around too there's
a bit of a checklist for you to know
that you actually got offers that are
going to get you one two three High
ticket clients a day automatically first
problem alignment have you strategically
choosen a symptomatic problem that's
likely Ur uring four people struggling
with the core problem right so that's
the first thing again choose an actual
symptomatic problem where you know that
there's big chances that the people who
have that also have the core problem
then the core problem awareness do you
deliver the low ticket offer in a format
that allows you to educate your buyers
on the present of the core problem while
you solve the symptomatic problem and
while doing so build High ticket offer
awareness where you can tell your buyers
hey there is an actual High ticket offer
or if you choose to high ticket onramp
there's a high ticket on-ramp that can
solve either the journey problems or the
core problems and I had that as an
optional here the high ticket on RAM do
have you introduced that mid ticket
offer as a natural Next Step what I
going to show you right now
is an actual manifestation of what that
looks like so here's an example this is
the 4-Hour Consulting model there again
essentially inside I am helping people
to create low and mid ticket offers and
when they end up purchasing this what
they get sent to is my mid ticket offer
which is essentially as I showed you
before I'm going to give you all the
internal client getting strategies DM
scripts messenger ready off first
etc
etc now I told you before that this is a
specific training that I will share with
my clients inside the 4-Hour Consulting
bundle es essentially what you're
looking at right now we still have some
open spots for that we're closing
enrollments on Friday so this is I think
the 208th of February we have I think 10
spots left it's it's it it's that 20
people if you want to get in on that
then let me know like sent me an email
sent me a message with bundle and I'll
share with you all the information and
the payment link to get started with it
it's essentially either
$218 once or $100 a week and if you
choose to do one-on-one with me instead
of like being in the community and going
through the trainings and just having me
do it all alongside you
then that would be
$1,200 I can quickly show you what that
looks like so essentially the 4our
Consulting bundle exists out of three
components one you got my classroom very
again inside you got all of my existing
client getting strategies templates
offers funnels everything that I'm using
inside my own business you get access to
right away which uh you can find in the
classroom then second component is we
meet twice a week for office hours where
we can craft offers where I can answer
your questions we can look at generating
traffic and all the things needed to
actually fill your offers and customize
it to you and we have the community
where you get fast feedback day in day
out as you can see here inside the
community right now so this is you get
access to all of that for four weeks for
$218 or $100 a week for um the four
weeks and if you choose oneon-one very
essentially instead of going through the
classroom yourself going through that
training yourself then it's $1,200 very
essentially I'm just doing it all
alongside you over Zoom calls you get my
phone number you get my calendar link
you can book time with me whenever you
need it but that is essentially it if
you are interested in joining Dad then
sent me an email sent me a message and
um I'll get you set up for this offer